مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم اتمنى لكم ليله
سعيده وتكون كل ايامكم سعيده وكل سنه
وحضراتكم طيبين بمناسبه الايام المباركه
اللي احنا بنعيشها
الاسئله بدات بالفعل
هل صحيح ان السعوديه هي الدوله الوحيده ده
امين هل صحيح ان السعوديه الدوله الوحيده
في العالم بلا دستور وان صح ذلك فلماذا لا
تقوم المملكه بتقنين دستور لا ما اعرفش
انه ما عرفش انه معرفش وضع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه فيما يتعلق بالدستور
والله نقطه مهمه تستحق من الواحد يترحل
لكن حكايه دوله بيلا دستور المملكه
المتحده بريطانيا ليس لها دستور مكتوب
ولما اسرائيل
ارادت ان هي تتحايل على عدم كتاب الدستور
لاسباب هقولها لحضراتكم استشهدت
بالبريطانيا العظمى التي ليس لها دستور
مكتوب
البريطانيا ليس لها دستور مكتوب لانها
بتعتمد على مجموعه من الاعراف الثابته لكن
ما عندهاش دستور مكتوب زي
زي مثلا في الولايات المتحده ودول اخرى
اسرائيل ما عندهاش دستور لان كان عندها
مشكله ان الدستور بيقتدي انه
لازم تكون في حدود محدده تنصه عليها
وبالتالي لانها لا تريد ان تلتزم بحدود زي
مدافد بينجوريون ففضل عدم كتابه دستور
متعللا بان هذا ليس امرا غريبا
انه في ذلك يفعل كما فعلت بريطانيا اما
بالنسبه للمملكه اذا اجابه سؤال حضرتك
هناك دول ليس لها دستور زي بريطانيا وزي
اسرائيل اما السعوديه
فهذا السؤال يعني
يستحق البحث
سلام عليكم سيد جبيل هل سترى تصعيد هل
سنرى تصعيد بين ايران وتركيا بسبب خلاف
اذربيجان مع ارمينيا على الممر الشهير
طبعا بتقول حضرتك
والله اصله ده يتوقف انت عارف ان الصدام
بين ارمينيا وادربعيجان موجود من
التسعينات والحقيقه
ظهر في التسعينات بشكل علني لكنه كان
موجود كمان في السنوات الاخيره للاتحاد
السوفيتي
وعلى مدار 35 سنه على الاقل يعني من
التسعينات بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
احيانا الصراع بينهما يؤدي الى توتر قوه
خارجيه من بينها ايران
وتركيا واحيانا لا
فهل سنرى تصعيدا
التوتر موجود على نقاط كتيره يتوقف
المساله وقتها على نوع المشكله وعلى مواقف
تركيا وعلى مواقف ايران يعني
انا عاوز اقول ان الدول دي اعتدت في
الفتره الاخيره مش الدول دي بس مش ايران
وتركان اعتدت ان هي تدير علاقات مقبوله
وجيده في ظل خلافات شديده جدا جدا جدا
ودله تناولناه قبل كده في حلقه بعنوان
الفرانمي او العدو الصديق ازاي تبقى دوله
ودوله عندهم خلافات عنيفه جدا الى درجه ان
هم بيحاربوا بعض بالوكاله زي مثلا تركيا
وروسيا وفي نفس الوقت اصدقاء ويتعاونوا في
ملفات اخرى
طبعا ده السؤال بتاع اخونا احمد صفاء
بتقول سلامي للجميع اهلا وسهلا استاذه
صفاء
معتصم استاذ سيد لا استطيع ان افهم لماذا
قتل خاشقجي في القنصليه علما انهم كانوا
يستطيعون قتله في اي مكان عام عبر قتله
الماجورين لعلهم قصدوا فعل ذلك لغايه ما
او هناك شيء
بالخفاء لا نعلمه والله يا معتصم يعني هم
ادرى بهذا اللي عمله كده لا احد يعلم لكن
التفسير اللي بيقدموه وطبعا المساله محل
التحقيقات ان المساله خرجت برا ايديهم
واخفقوا وكان النيه في ان هو يتم احضاره
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه على العموم
الحكومه السعوديه
تبرات من القصه برمتها يعني قالت ان هذه
مجموعه اخطاتها فتحا
ما عنديش اجابه لسؤالك
عمرو السيد الصوت
لو سمحت الصوت نايس يعني مش عارف يعني ايه
صوت عمرو
نعليه حالا
احمد هاي اهلا وسهلا حسام منور استاذنا
الرائع الله يحفظك
اي مساء الخير استاذ سيد مساء النور يا
صديقي
الصوت اعلى حاجه طيب تمام ما فيش مشاكل
يعني طيب يمكن عند حضرتك انت محتاج تعلي
جهازك حسن بيقول ان الدين العالمي يزداد
بمرور الزمن الا تظن انه سوف ياتي يوم
تكون الدول عاجزه عن السداد ما هو رايك
بهذا الا تظن ان هذا اقتصاد مثل السراب
تسديد الديون بالديون هذه قصه يا استاذ
حسن طبعا يعني بالغه الحساسيه انا على
المستوى الشخصي عندي يعني اهتمام كبير
بمتابعتها ولما بسال يعني او انا حاولت
افهم انا ليه مهتم بموضوع الديون واتكلمت
عنه مش بس في اليوتيوب قبل كده كصحفي يعني
اكتشفت انه اهتمام طبيعي بالنسبه انا صحفي
مصري
ومصر احتلت بسبب الديون الجزائر احتلت
بسبب مطالبتها فرنسا انها تدفع الدين يقول
لها سبب عكسي المنطقه ديون استغلت في
الدول الناميه كتير بشكل سيء جدا دمرتها
الديون انما حضرتك بتقول انه هل يمكن ان
تكون هناك دول عاجزه عن السداد في دول
عجزت على السند بالفعل
فده مش ممكن ده حدث كثيرا قبل ذلك والان
هناك وفقا لصندوق النادي الدولي نحو خمسين
دوله من الدول طبعا الناميه والفقيره
مهدده بالعجز عن سداد ديونها هذا امر وارد
جدا
وطبعا وانت بتقول اقتصاد مثل السراب ايوه
اقتصاد مثل السراب طبعا لان انت بتسدد دين
بدين وبالمناسبه ده في الحكومات
الديكتاتوريه وفي الحكومات الديمقراطيه
الديكتاتوريه لانه لا رقيب ولا حسيب اذا
ما كانش رشيد وفي الديمقراطيات بتكون
حكومه منتخب ايوه بس يهمها ان هي ترضي
الناس الان على حساب
الرشاد في المستقبل يعني انا اقترض ورده
ناس ورده مرتبات واوظف وارحل مشكله
السادات لاداره اخرى تاتي بعدي
بالمناسبه في سؤال دايما بيتكرر كتير بما
ان انت طرحت مساله الديون وكان طرحه احد
الاصدقاء
ويعني ما تمكناش من اجابته
اجمالي الدين الجلوبي للعالمي كله حوالي
350 تريليون دولار والناتج المحلي للعالم
حوالي 100 تريليون يعني الدين اكتر من
ثلاث امثال الناتج المحلي الاجمالي ودايما
الناس كانت بتسال من اين تستدين الدول
يعني اذا كان العالم كله مستدين ب 350
تريليون من اين يستديروا الاجابه على هذا
السؤال اولا هو موجود على نعرف اقتصاد بس
ببساطه لو عاوز اجابه مختصره جدا اي بنك
بيكون راس ماله زي مثلا 100 ممكن تجد ان
هو اقرب المئه ديت
3400 يعني ثلاث اربع امثال بفكره
الملتبلاير انا بدل حضرتك قرض عباره عن
1000 انت بتاخد الالف دي زي مثلا كشركه
مقاولات وبعدين بتشتري بها معدات
وبتشتري
انت عاوزه يعني انت علشان تشتري بها معدات
انت بتقطعها في بنك اخر البنك الاخر
بيقرضها لغيرك وهكذا ففكره الاقراض لو
عندك فكره عن مفهوم الملتبلاير هنفهم ليه
ان دايما القروض اكثر من الاصول يعني
احمد
السيد انت قدوه ربنا يخليك يا استاذ احمد
شكرا جزيلا لكلامك الطيب
بيقول اهلا سيد استاذ سيد شكرا جزيلا
مجهوداتك الهائله في التنوير ارجو ان
تعطينا اسماء افضل المواقع والكتب
لتعلم الاقتصاد باحترافيه وكذلك افضل
قنوات اليوتيوب بالنسبه لافضل القنوات
اليوتيوب والله ما اقصد حاجه فعلا انا مش
بتابع لان انا يعني هابط على اليوتيوب من
من جيل مختلف ايوه صحيح ان في ناس دلوقتي
في سني واكبر مني دخلوا الى اليوتيوب وما
شاء الله يعني في ناس في
الستينات والسبعينات ومن اساتذتنا الكتاب
والسياسيين بداوا بس ده حاجه جديده خالص
لكن انا لما دخلت اظن ما كانش في ناس
كتيره من جيلي كانوا عندهم معرفه
باليوتيوب وظلت حتى الان لها علاقه لي
باليوتيوب سوى ما اقدمه انا ولا اعلم الا
لما بيكون احد اصدقائي
بيبعت لي حاجه اشوفها طبعا انا عارف ان في
بعض
المقدمه المحتوى المحترمين جدا
عندهم قنوات واحنا اصدقائي يعني لكن انا
ما بيسمحليش الوقت بمتابعه القنوات عشان
اقول ما هو الافضل ده بالامانه يعني اما
بالنسبه للمواقع اللي بتعلمك اقتصاد
اختار عليك نعرف اقتصادي الاول
شف نعرف اقتصاده وهي معموله لكده لاننا
نعرف اقتصاد مع صديقي الاقتصاد المحترم
هاني جنينه هدفها ان احنا نعلق على احداث
بس نجيب جذورها من الاساس
اذا ما كنتش عاوز نعرف اقتصاد او حاجه جنب
نعرف اقتصاد فاذا كنت تعرف لغه انجليزيه
استطيع ان اكتب لك في اسفل الحلقه او في
حلقه مقبله قائمه
بعدد لا يعصى من المواقع بس للاسف باللغه
الانجليزيه اما باللغه العربيه يفعلها
اعرف للاسف الشديد المحتوى بالعربي ضعيف
جدا سواء في الاقتصاد او في السياسه
احمد
احمد بيقول ازاي الدول زي البرازيل
والارجنتين وتركيا تخلصت من النظم
العسكريه صعب احمد الاجابه على السؤال
التلاته كل دوله لها ظروفها بس اديك مثال
سريع يعني انت عندك بلد زي تركيا
اوديك اجابه عامه وبعد كده ممكن بقى كل
دوله له ظروفها انت بيبقى عندك
يعني
انتقال الدوله من الديكتاتوريه انتقال
الدوله من النظم الملكيه الشموليه انتقال
الدوله من من النظم العسكريه
ده علشان تنتقل الى نظم ديمقراطيه منتخبة
بالكامل وفي انتقال سلطه عمليه بتاخد
عشرات السنين عشرات السنين من التطور
الانقلابات والازمات
والمظاهرات والاحتجاجات والثورات وضحايا
كتير علشان مجتمع يستقر ويقول ان هذا هو
اختياري وبالمناسبه عدد الدول اللي نجح في
انه يتجاوز
الديكتاتوريات باشكالها المختلفه عسكريه
او غير عسكريه مش كتير قوي يعني عدد الدول
واللي تجاوزها بنجاح كبير دول كفح 300 سنه
و400 سنه واحنا اتكلمنا على القصه دي كتير
زي الدول اللي احنا بنتكلم عليها دايما في
اوروبا الغربيه والولايات المتحده خدوا
مئات السنين من الكفاح علشان يستقروا
ووصلوا الى ما وصلوا اليه بلد زي تركيا
ظلت كذلك الى وقت قريب جدا جدا لغايه
منتصف التسعينات كان في لانه
يعني اربكان نجم الدين اربكان اطيح به في
انقلاب ناعم في منتصف التسعينات في لغايه
منتصف التسعين كانت في مشكله لغايه 2016
كان في محاوله للانقلاب على رجب طيب
اردوغان وتركيا اللي حققت يعني تراجع في
نفوذ العسكريين واللي حصل فيها انقلاب
2016 كان برضو حصل فيها رده رده دي عباره
عن انه اردوغان ايوه عنده جمهوره بينجح في
انتخابات يعني
بتلقى مصداقيه وقبول الى حد كبير يعني
كويس انما نسبه الحريه فيها مقارنه
بالديمقرايه المستقله ديمقراطيات المستقله
حدث فيها تراجع كبير في السنوات الاخيره
واحيلك الى
مفهوم كويس ابحثوا فيه يعني بعد الحلقه
براحتكم اللي هو
الديمقراطيات غير الليبراليه اللي روج له
الصحفي الامريكي او الكاتب الامريكي الهند
الاصلي الدكتور فريد زكريا اللي كان رئيس
تحرير نيوزويك اي انتشار نوع جديد من
الديمقراطيات اللي بتعتمد على الصندوق بس
لكن في حقيقه الامر ان هي مش قادره تطبق
النموذج اللي ظهر الناس في الولايات
المتحده وفي المانيا وفي فرنسا اللي فيها
بقى انتقال ثالث للسلطه وفي انتخابات
عادله جدا
وفيها حريات ناس بتحترم فيها حرياتهم
وهكذا يعني
اذا الاجابه المختصره جدا لك ان هم خدوا
عشرات السنوات من التطور وعلى فكره كمان
في عنصر تاني دايما مسكوت عنه ان معظم هذه
الدول
وجدت دعما كبيرا من العالم الخارجي عشان
يساعدها في الانتقال
من
ديكتاتوريتها الى نظم اكثر
ديمقراطيه وبالمناسبه برضو في كتاب مهم
للدكتور علي الديني هلال استاذنك اكتب
الدكتور علي الدين هلال
الديمقراطيه انا مش فاكر اسم الكتاب
بالضبط او الانتقال الى الديمقراطيه كتاب
اللغه العربيه وهو كتاب عظيم جدا جدا رغم
ان عدد صفحات وليست كبيره يساعدك في
الاجابه على السؤال وفي امثله من بعض
الدول اللي انت اشرت اليها
قولي يا عمرو قول
ايه رايك في
الواقع ده عمرو بيقول لي ان يوسف بعد سؤال
بيتكلم على احداث غزه
وبيلحها عليه يعني
الله يا اخونا يوسف اللي بيحصل في غزه هو
اللي بيحصل بشكل دوري يعني
انت عندك
جوهر الصراع بات مفهوما او جوهر الاحتقان
بات مفهوما الناس في غزه الناس في الضفه
الغربيه لهم حقوق وليهم تطلعات هذه الحقوق
وهذه
التطلعات مصادر عليها ولا يوجد امل في
الحصول عليها
واسرائيل عندها قناعه وبتزداد هذه القناعه
تحت حكم جماعات متطرفه انا اتكلمت عنها
اكتر من مره واخرها الدواعش يحكمون
اسرائيل
وحلقه يعني الناس انصرفت عن مضمونها
وكلمتني عن حاجه او بعض الناس يعني كلمتني
عن حاجات يعني
خارج الموضوع الحقيقه لكن
حكومه بالغه التطرف هي كانت قبل كده
حكومات
استعماريه استيطانيه لكن دي حكومه حكومه
استيطانيه وبالغه التطرف دينيا وترى انها
على حق
مدعومه يعني باراده الله في التوراه
وشايفه انه الفلسطينيين ليس لهم حق في
ابداء اي اعتراض ولا حتى في الوجود على
اراضي يهودا والسامره وعليه
اي احتكاك هيحصل اي تصرف من اي فلسطيني
هيكون النتيجه ان هم هيردوا عليه بعنف اي
رد فعل زي اللي حصل
بتصفيه اربعه من المستوطنين اللي موجودين
على الاراضي الفلسطينيه هذه الحكومه مضطره
حتى تبرر بقائها وسياستها ان هي ترد
باضعاف من العنف وبالتالي من وقت للثاني
عمليه عنف بتم او عمليه قهر ما فيش فيها
جديد ابدا واحيانا ما يكونش الفلسطينيين
عملوا حاجه خالص غير انه الحكومه اللي
موجوده تريد لاي اسباب داخليه ان هي تلهي
الراي العامل الاسرائيلي
بالاعتداء على الفلسطينيين عاوز تلخص اللي
بيحصل بكلمه واحده
الاسرائيليون يفعلون ذلك بقاصدي كامل
لانهم يستطيعون ان يفعلوا ذلك لا اكثر ولا
اقل
محمد بيقول اردوغان
قال ان ارمينيا لا تعارض ممر
زنجور بين اذربيجان
وتركيا ولكن ايران هي من تعارض هل ارمينيا
تخضع لطهران لكن
لكي لا يكون
كل بيضهم في سله روسيا اعتقدوا هو نفس
السؤال هي الفكره لو كان معي خريطه انا
كنت وضحت لحضرتك بس يعني مش عارف اذا كان
كل الناس
القصه كلها ان الممر ده اللي ممكن يربط
ارمينيا اللي ممكن يضرب يربط اذربيجان
بتركيا وبيمر من الاراضي الارمنيه اذا حدث
هذا يعني ارمينيا اولا مش موافقه على ده
الا بعد ان يكون جزء من
حلل كل القضايا العالقه بين ارمان
وارمينيا والا اذا تم هذا الممر كانها
بتكافئ اضرب ايجان للعدوان عليها وكانها
بتكافئ تركيا لدعمها اضرب ايجان في صراعها
ضد ارمينيا ده من ناحيه وبالتالي هي بتقول
انتم عاوزين تستغلوا هذا الممر لازم هذا
الممر يكون جزء من تسويه كبيره وشامله
بالنسبه لايران اذا حدث ده هي هتتضرر
لانها تفقد جزء من اهميتها لان في عدم
وجود هذا الممر على الكثير من الطرق اللي
بتربط اذربيجان بتركيا بتمر عبر الاراضي
الايرانيه
اخر شيء
ده اخونا دراما اخر شيء كان ممكن يخطر على
بالي موقف مصر مؤخرا من الاسد ومقاب
مطالبتها بتطبيق القرار 22/54 في سوريا
والرد من اعلام النظام بالتهام مصر بدعم
الارهاب استاذ سيد ما السر في انقلاب
الموقف مؤخرا لا انا ما عنديش التفاصيل
اللي انت بتقول عليها واتهام السوريين اذا
كنت بتتكلم على صحفيين او مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي فلا اعلم انما لو عندك تصريح
لطول سوري بيقول ان مصر بتدعم الارهاب يا
ريت تبعته لي تبعته لي ازاي لو عندك
دلوقتي ابعته لي اذا ما كانش على فيسبوك
الصفحه العامه ابعتلي رساله اما هذا اللي
انت بتقول عليه ده ممكن يكون بقى صحفيين
ولا موقع تواصل اجتماعي او هكذا يعني اي
حاجه يعني
السلام عليكم هل حضرتك بتؤمن بنظريه
المؤامره ده محمد سيد
في فرق بين المؤامره ونظريه المؤامره
المؤامره اللي هي كنسبرسي او بلاط يعني ان
حد يتامر على حد دوله تتامر على دوله ده
موجود كل يوم وبكثافه ولا توجد دوله لا
تتامر على الدول الاخرى
نظريه المؤامره تعريفها من وجهه نظري هو
ان تخاف من او تقلق من شيء لا يوجد دليل
عليه يعني بمعنى اصح مثلا تقول انه زي
مثلا انه الدول الغربيه بتتربص بالدول
الاسلاميه وبتسعى
لجعلها متخلفه مثلا هل عندك اي دليل عندك
اي حاجه معينه لا ما يكونش فيها دليل تقول
مثلا انه الدول بتحاول ان هي عاوزه
تهد الاقتصاد الجزائري مين هم اللي يهدوا
الاقتصاد الجزائري كل الدول الغربيه او
انه وهكذا يعني
هل عندك دليل انا ما عنديش دليل على حاجه
لا نظريه المؤامره بمعنى ان انت عندك
مخاوف وسيبك من السياسه ان هم عملوا
الفكسيه عملوا مثلا
في الولايات المتحده في الفتره المقبله
يعني لانه التضخم ما زال مرتفع
والبنك المركزي او الفيدرالي الامريكي غير
قادر على انه
او لم يستطع ان يروضه كما كان يامل بسهوله
يعني
ويبدو ان الدكتور محمد العريان الاقتصادي
الامريكي المصري كان محقا لما قال انه
الفيدرالي الامريكي يفشل لانه تاخر كثيرا
في التدخل حين كان يجب ان يتدخل تاخر في
التدخل فانفلتت الامور
هل هناك محاولات للوب الصهيوني في الصين
وما مدى نجحهم اذا كان تقصي قلوب الصيني
في اللوبي يهودي في الصين لا اعلم عنه ولم
اسمع عنه ولا اعتقد انه موجود ولكن
الموجود محاولات اصل انت عشان يكون عندك
لوبي اللوبي الصهيوني اللي في امريكا ده
انت مش بتكون شركه علاقات عامه زي الدول
العربيه ما بتعمل وبتدفع مثلا عضو كونكر
السابق فيحاول يوصل وجهه نظرك للناس ده
كده اسمها شركات بي ار او شركات بتعمل دور
محدود بيحاول يوصل وجهه نظرك لدى دوله انت
مش عارف توصل وجهه نظرك كل الدول العربيه
بقت تعمل كده تجيب شركه متخصصه في هذا
الامر في العلاقات العامه السياسيه وتدفع
لهم والشركه ديت بتحاول تعمل لك حمله توصل
وجهه نظرك للكونجرس لايك والولايات
المتحده قوانينها تسمح بذلك انما اللوبي
اللوبي زي اللوبي الص
ده متجذف في الولايات المتحده لاسباب لا
يمكن تتوفر في الصين يعني انت عندك اليهود
مستقرين بشكل تلقائي من مئات السنين في
الولايات المتحده اليهود نافذون في
الولايات المتحده بشكل تلقائي واورجانيك
مدرسين يهود في المدارس والجامعات كتاب
يهود شعراء يهود صحفيين مؤثرين موجودين
اليهود سياسيين موجودين في وزاره الخارجيه
والدفاع الى اخره
الدين انه انا يهودي وهناك طيار في
المسيحيه بيقول طيار في المسيحيه بيعتقد
انه كل مصيره مرتبط بمصير اليهود اذا
تجمعوا
المسيح وتبدا الالفيه الجديده وهكذا يعني
قصه طويله فده حاجه اورجانيك حاجه طبيعيه
الشعور بالذنب الامريكي تجاه اليهود اللي
هم اضطهدوا في في
المانيا تحديدا يعني شعور بالذنب كان شعور
تلقائي استغل بعد ذلك لكن كان شعور تلقائي
وهكذا انما كل ده مش موجود في حالات الصين
انما اللي موجود صديقي الاستاذ
دادياف انه اسرائيل من بدري من عده سنوات
وهي حريصه مع صعود الصين ان تقوي علاقاتها
مع الصين وعارضت نفسها كشريك رئيسي في
مشروع الحزام والطريق وبدات تدخل في شركات
مع الصين وبدات ان هي تسمح لها بتطوير عدد
من الموانئ
واستثمارات اسرائيليه في الصين واستثمارات
صينيه في اسرائيل وهكذا
هل ستؤثر خطه محطه اسرائيل
العائمه على خطه مصر لتصبح مركز تصدير
الغاز لا اعلم محطه اسرائيل العائمه لا
اعلم يا صديقي اذا كنت بتتكلم على محطه
تسهيل غاز او شيء كمان هذا استاذنك تكتب
لي علشان ما اجاوبش على حاجه انا يعني مش
فاهم قصدك فيها ايه
هي عموما لو بتتكلم هو ايه مصدر يعني
النقطه دي اذا كنت فهمت سؤالك القصه كلها
فين مصر عندها محطتين ازاله غاز يعني انت
بتبعت الغاز المحطتين دول محطتين كبار
تكلفتهم كثيره انا وقتها اظن يعني اظن
دلوقتي هم الاثنين تكلفتهم في حدود كل
واحده عشره وعشره في حدود في حدود لما كنت
بسال يعني في حدود الاثنين عشرين مليار
دولار
[موسيقى]
المحطتين دول عندهم القدره انك لما توصلوا
توصل لهم الغاز من انبوب يسيلوه ولما
يسيلوه يستطيع السفن ان تحمله مسالا في
ثانكس الى اي مكان في العالم
اي حد ممكن يعمل محطه الاساله وبالتالي
اسرائيل ممكن تعمله تركيا ممكن تعمله بس
بيحصل ايه مين اللي هيعمله الحكومه
التركيه مش هتعملوا الحكومه الاسرائيليه
مش هتعمله ولكن بتاعها اليه لا شركات
فتيجي شركه تقول انا الاختيار قدامي
كالاتي انا عندي غاز
استنى ابعت الغاز ده لمصر اللي هي عندها
محطتين مجرد اوصل لها انبوب وهي تسيل
الغاز ومجرد تاخد حق تسهيله
وخصوصا ان الانبوب اوريدي موجود من
اسرائيل لمصر لان هو نفس الانبوب اللي كان
بيحمل الغاز المصري الاسرائيلي ايام مبارك
ولا استعين بشركه اعرض عليها ان هي تبني
محطتين تدفع عشرين مليار دولار وتحتاج الى
خمس الى ست سنوات وبعد خمس ست سنوات
الشركه دي هتبدا تعمل اللي مصر بتعمله
مثلا من عشره 15 سنه
وشركه اللي هيقعد اليها او هيطلب منها
تقول طب انا هعمل مشروع ممكن الاقي نفسي
في منافسه مع بلد عندها المشروع قائم
والبنيه التحتيه موجوده وبالتالي هذا ليس
مستحيلا ان تفعله اسرائيل ولكن الجدول
الاقتصاديه هي اللي شجعت اسرائيل واليونان
وقبرص الا تستثمر في محطات اساله بينما هي
موجوده على مرمى البصر من
شواطئهم
على الشواطئ المصريه
احمد عبد الله بيقول ما سبب
احمد عبد الله بيقول ما سبب التحركات
العسكريه في امريكا وكندا والمكسيك لا
اعلم يا صديقي ما سبب التحركات العسكريه
هناك
فهد السلطان الصراحه كل اسبوع ممكن تكون
ممله للمستمعين ومتعبه لك يا استاذنا حاضر
نعيد النظر في مساله كل اسبوع نعمل
استفتاء تاني لا باس على كل الاحوال كل
سنه وانتم طيبين ان شاء الله الاربعاء
الجايه هيكون عيد اجازه
هل سيتم تقويم الجنيه مره اخرى في مصر
يقينا نعم لكن ما اعلنه الرئيس الرئيس
المصري انه هذا التعويم ليس قريبا في هذه
الظروف الحاليه وعليه توقعت كثير من
البنوك انه بما انه رئيس الدوله قال كده
انه التعويم ليس في القريب العاجل لكن
المنطقي يقول انه بما انه في سعر موازي
وفي سعر حقيقي لا تستطيع ان
[موسيقى]
تنفذ يعني ما تقدرش تاخد 30 جنيه وتقول
للبنك الديني بهم دولار يبقى لازم هيحصل
تعويم اخر انت بقى ده هو اللي مش واضح لنا
يعني
العلاقه ما هي العلاقه بين روسيا وجورجيا
النهارده الاسئله كتير عن جورجيا وارمينيا
حلقه عليهم اكتبوا ده انا عندي حلقه
عملتها مجهزها من شهور وبعدين اعتقدت ان
انتم مش هتهتموا العلاقه بين روسيا
وجورجيا علاقه قويه ومتينه وجيده عاوز
اقول لحضرتك كانت ارمينيا واذربيجان انت
بتقول جورجيا ولا ايه انا اسف انا فهمت
السؤال غلط انت بتتكلم على جورجيا لا
جورجيا طبعا العلاقه ليست جيده
لانه جورجيا كانت من الدول عامله زي
اوكرانيا
وهي اراده الانضمام مبكرا الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي وكان عندها
توجه غربي من الفين من 2004 و2005 وهكذا
يعني ودي كانت اول دوله تتدخل فيها روسيا
الاتحاديه بعدما يعني استقرت الاوضاع فيها
بعد سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي ثم
اضطرابات الكتيره اللي جت في روسيا ثم
بدات تستقر مع وجود بوتين كانت اول عمليه
عسكريه كبيره تمت من جانب روسيا الاتحاديه
في 2008 حرب الخمسه ايام واللي
استردت فيها او
سيطرت فيها روسيا
على
[موسيقى]
اظن ابخزيه انا ناسي اسم الاقليم ولكن كان
في اقليم واراضي هناك فيها اغلبيه وروسيه
روسي قالت ان الروس هناك زي ما قالت في
اوكرانيا يتعرضون للاضطهاد فدخلت هناك
وسيطرت على الاقليم وظل الداعمه هناك
للروس او المواطنين الجورجيين من اصل روسي
وبالتالي العلاقات متوتره جدا طبعا وقطعت
الطريق على انضمام جورجيا لحلف شمال
الاطلسي
ديفيد امير معك داود امير ما هو سبب حماس
الشركات لدعم جامعات المثليين والمتحولين
جنسيا ان اغلب السكان في العالم اما ترفض
او لا تدعم الموضوع لماذا
لماذا لا الشركات الداعمه
لماذا لا تخف الشركات الداعمه من تكبد
خسائر بسبب المقاطعه
هي
هو مش الشركات اللي اخترعت القصه ممكن
تكون في بعض الشركات مستفيده لكن فكره ان
الشركات
بتروج لان هي مستفيده مساله فيها نظر
القصه على النحو التالي في السنوات
الاخيره يعني مثلا من عشرين وتلاتين سنه
القصه ما كانتش مطروحه وفي حلقه موجوده
على القناه عن لماذا تدعم يدعم الغرب او
تدعم الولايات المتحده حقوق المثليين
الفكره في انه
بدات حقوق المثليين زي كجزء من
طفره كبيره جدا في توجهات
الليبراليين في الولايات المتحده الناس
اللي بيقولوا انه
مشغولين جدا بفكره الحريات وحقوق كل
الاقليات الدينيه والعرقيه والجنسيه هذا
التيار زادت قوته بالمناسبه معظمه موجود
في الحزب الديمقراطي
وبالمناسبه ايضا بقدر ما الناس شايفاه ان
هو مستفز لدعم لحقوقه المثليين هنا في
الشرق الاوسط وكمان داعم لحقوق المسلمين
داعم لحقوق اليهود دعم لحقوق هو بيدعم كل
الاقليات اللي هو شايفها في اي بلد من
البلدان يعني
اللي ممكن تشوف نموذج عنه يعني موجود في
القنوات اللي هي اللي بتاعه الستريمنج او
شركات الستريمنج زي نتفليكس دايما طول
الوقت بتتكلم على المجتمع الشامل فلازم
دايما يجيب لك مثلي اذا كان رجل او سيده
ويجيب لك بنت محجبه بتشتغل في السي اي ايه
ويجيب لك واحد اسوء واحد كذا
سيبك من نتفليكس شوف اداره الرئيس بايدن
هتجدها هتجدها ان هي
بتمثل هذا التيار
الاداره بتشمل عدد كبير جدا من المثليين
والمتحولين جنسيا وطبعا من الاقليات
التينيه وهكذا يعني
التيار ده قوي
لو لو انا عديت سؤال وقلنا يا عمرو عشان
انا خايف الناس تفتكر انه في اسئله افضل
من الاسئله يعني انا واخد الاسئله
بالترتيب عمرو بيقول ان في بعض الاسئله
فلما التيار ده بقى اصبح قويا جدا ولما
بقت تنص على حقوق هؤلاء المثليين وزاره
المساله واصبحت مساله حساسه زي مثلا في
فترات سابقا انك تتكلم على ان تمثل ان
تشكك فيه اصبحت الشركات تخاف من ان تتعرض
الى الكنسلينج ان انت في امريكا اذا قلت
ان الهوليكوست محل جدل يؤركنسل دعوه انت
خلاص انت ما بتشاركش في اي حاجه انت ما
تنتجش انت ما تكتبش انت يغلق عنك تماما
هذه الشركات لها مصالح شايفه انه الغرب
والولايات المتحده اللي هي ربع اقتصاد
العالم هذا هو شانها فالشركات بصفه عامه
بتقول انا مش عاوزه اتاذي فانا كمان هسمح
بانه المثليين يمثلوا زي ما هم في الاداره
الامريكيه انا مش هاخد منهم موقف وهكذا
يعني انما في شركات
قليله بتستثمر في هذا المجال تستثمر ازاي
انا مش خبير بقى مش عارف بيعملوا ايه يعني
لكن مثلا الحاجات اذا كانت حاجات عمليه
التحول الجنسي ولا كذا بس دي عددهم صغير
قوي قوي قوي ودول زي اي شركات بتستفيد من
بيزنس معين لاكثر ولا اقل يعني
مستقبل الدولار في سوريا الفتره المقبله
شكرا جزيلا
السلام عليكم ده روبرت عليكم السلام امجد
كيف تتوقع نهايه الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا لا يعني انا حقيقه مش انا توقعي
انه لا حديث الان عن نهايه الحرب على
الاقل قبل 202 كل المؤشرات بتقول انه
الولايات المتحده اللي هي اهم الطرف من من
يعني في مواجهه الروس يعني ان بالاضافه
الى الدول الداعمه لاوكرانيا المختلفه
واوكرانيا وطبعا روسيا من الناحيه التانيه
كلهم بيستعدوا الى باريل لحرب طويله جدا
جدا جدا
وحتى بقى كبار المسؤولين زي رئيس الفرنسي
ومسؤولين اخرين بيقولوا علينا ان نستعد
يعني لحرب تنتهي بقى ممكن النظر في
نهايتها بعد انتهاء الانتخابات الامريكيه
اللي هي هتعقد في نوفمبر 202 ولما يجي
الرئيس الجديد اذا كان نفس الرئيس ولا
رئيس اخر سوف ينظر في فاحنا قدام
حرب طويله
هل تستطيع ده خليل بيقول هل تستطيع في
المستقبل ان توحد عمله عربيه وان توجد
عمله عربيه موحده يقينا لا يا صديقي يعني
هذا غير مطروح ابدا ابدا حتى تجربه مجلس
التعاون الخليجي اللي كانت يعني واعيده
الى حد ما دول متجانسه وقريبه واقتصاديا
متشابهه فشلت تماما بسبب الخلافات العنيفه
بين الدول
وعدم الثقه فيما بينها عدم الثقه الى الحد
ان هم رفضوا حتى انه يوحدوا فيما بينهم او
ينسقوا دفعتهم الجويه وما تنساش ان
الخلافات ضاربه في دول الخليج الى احنا
لسه سامعين بس انه قطر والبحرين اعادوا
علاقتهم الدبلوماسيه كانت متوتره وسيئه
وكانت العلاقه بين قطر
[موسيقى]
البحرين والسعوديه والامارات بالغه السوء
وكان هناك خلاف سعودي الكويتي على حقل
بترول لغايه فتره ليست بعيده وعارف ان
سلطنه عمان لا يريد ان يكون لها شان مع
باقي دول الخليج هي بتقول انا وحدي سياستي
منفرده عارفين ان قطر لا تريد ان تكون تحت
مظله الدول مجلس التعاون التي تقودها
السعوديه طب انا ليه اتكلمت كل ده عن
الخريطه انت بتتكلم عن العالم العربي اذا
كان هذا ينطبق على
مجموع الدول عدد سكانهم صغير نسبيا اجمالي
عدد السكان في دول الخليج حوالي 53 مليون
اقتصادات متشابهه ثقافه متشابهه وفشلوا في
الحديث عن عمله موحده اذا فما بالك بقى
بالعالم العربي كله اللي هو
التباينات بينه اكبر بكثير والخلافات بينه
وفيما بينه يعني اعمق بكثير
وبالتالي غير مطروح
ما انا قلقان يا عمرو ان انا اعدي السؤال
حاضر لان انا بس واخد بالترتيب ده كويس لو
انا سبتهم خالص في الاخر بس انا قلقان
لاحسن حد يفتكر ان انا باخذ سؤال على سؤال
يعني عمرو يعني حابب ان في ناس بيقولوا
احنا اسئلتنا ما بتتاخدش فعاوز يقول
للاجابات مشكورا يعني بس انا خايف ان
الناس تفهم غلط يعني انا هاخد بالترتيب
وفي نهايه الحلقه ممكن
نشوف لو في سؤال احنا ما خدناهوش
لقد ذكرت من قبل نظريه الدوله الوحش
هل وجود قطب واحد في العالم خير من وجود
عدد اقطاب مثلا
العالم قبل
وباكس بريطانيكا والعالم بعده هو دوله
مالهاش علاقه بفكره انت بتتكلم كده على
الدوله على الدوله القطب الواحد الدوله
الوحشي يا صديقي وفي دوله بعنوان الدوله
الوحش
وبالمناسبه ده مرتبط بليه الدول تجاوزه
يعني كان مرتبط شويه بالسؤال ليه دول ما
بتقدرش تحقق الديمقراطيه
الدوله الوحش معناها انه دوله
نظريه قديمه
فيلسوفها كان بيقول انه بما ان احنا بنعيش
في فوضى فين الكلام ده فيه انجلترا
1600 وشويه والناس بتقتل بعضها في الشوارع
والناس لا تستطيع ان تامن على نفسها
ده توماس هوبز الفيلسوف البريطاني الشهير
الذي سمي بعد ذلك بفيلسوف المستبدين فقال
انا بقى لي عايش بقى لي 30 سنه في حرب
اهليه في بريطانيا وفي اوروبا
وناس بيدبحوا نفسهم في انجلترا وبيدبحوا
نفسهم الدول في الحروب المختلفه في اوروبا
كل ده بحثا عن يعني
فهو كان بيقترح انه انه الافضل للانسان
انه يامن على نفسه وانه علشان يامن على
نفسه ما يكونش فيه صراع ما بين الملك
والبرلمان او الملك والامراء اللي ممكن
ينتج عن حريه الدول دي ما كانتش مستعده
لها في القرن ال16 يعني فقال انا بايد
نظريه الدوله الوحش
اللي هو المخلوق الاسطوري دوت ان الدوله
يكون عندها او الملك او السفريند عنده
صلاحيات استثنائيه لا يسال عما يفعل في
مقابل ان يمنحنا امن الحياه حق الحياه
وبس يعني ودي كانت نظريه بنت وقتها
ومرتبطه بظروف هذا البلد انا كنت وجهه
نظري النظريه ديت الى حد كبير يعني ما
زالت قائمه في كثير من الدول الناميه
والفقيره انه عن ان في هذه الدول الحاكم
تقريبا طبعا ده على سبيل المبالغه يعني لا
يسال عما يفعل في مقابل انه بيدي للناس
حتى الحياه ان الشوارع امنه ان الناس ما
بتقتلش بعض في الشوارع وبس دي نظريه
الدوله الوحش
اللي انت بتقول عليه قصه تانيه انه نظريه
القطب الواحده والاقطاب امريكا مثلا انت
بتقول وهكلمك على بريطانيكا يعني
باكس امريكاني او باكس بريتانيكا او باكس
روما الى اخره انه يكون في دوله قطب واحد
زي ما كانت الولايات المتحده مثلا منذ
سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي حتى وقت قريب انه
هي صاحبه الكلمه الاولى والاخيره في معظم
شؤون العالم في مقابل دوله متعدده الاقطاب
او ثنائيه الاقطاب زي ما كانت الولايات
المتحده
والاتحاد السوفيتي هل ده افضل للعالم اكيد
مش افضل للعالم انه يكون في دوله واحده
[موسيقى]
اكيد لانه احنا جربنا لما كانت الدوله
الوحيده اللي هي الولايات المتحده عملت
ايه لما بيكون في نظامين قطبين بيحصل
توازن ولو ان الصراع بينهم بيهلك بعض
الدول اذا كان في تعدد اقطاب اكتر من دوله
ما جربناهاش يعني في تاريخنا الحديث ولكن
ربما يكون افضل وافضل كلمه افضل كلمه
نسبيه عاوزه دراسه يعني عشان تقول لكن
اللي انا واثق منه اللي مش عاوز دراسه ان
اذا كانت دوله عالم ذا تقود بين واحد اللي
هو تاكس امريكانا بكل حاجه بتحكمها
امريكانا امريكا او قبلها بريطانيا او
قبلها غيرها او في قطبين او في متعدد
الاقطاب افضل شيء ممكن يحفظ
لشعب ما حقوقه وحريته ان يكون لديه قدر
وافرد من القوه الذاتيه ده اللي ممكن
يحميك
اما ان انت تعتمد على قوه الاخرين اذا كنت
ضعيفا فسوف تهلك اذا كان النظام قطب واحد
او قطبين او متعدد الاقطاب
مساء الخير استاذ سيد جبيل يا ريت تعمل
حلقه مفصله عن رؤيه السعوديه 2030
نجتهد ان شاء الله
ده انت مسمي نفسك خطيئه الكسل اسمه يعني
درامي قوي ابراهيم سامي هل هل الخلل في
الديمقراطيه ام اننا نحن غير مؤهلين لها
لا الخلل مش في الديمقراطيه ومش ان احنا
غير مؤهلين لها المساله مساله تطور
واستاذنك ارجع لحلقه الدوله الوحش لان انا
عارض فيها الفكره انه انت على علشان كلمه
الديمقراطيه والليبراليه ان يكون عندك
انتقال سلس للسلطه
وانه الانتقال الثلاث للسلطه ده بيحدث ان
انت تحط صوتك في الانتخابات فياتي من تصوت
له معناها انه في دوله مواطنه
خد مثلا السودان
عشان السودان تنتقل الى الديمقراطيه
معناها ان كل سوداني له نفس الحقوق
والواجبات اذا كان من اصل افريقي من اصل
عربي اذا كان من الشمال او من الجنوب اذا
كان مسلم او مسيحي او من اي ديانه اخرى
وانه
ان في مؤسسات مستقره وقبل المؤسسات
المستقره لازم يكون في مستوى رفاه مقبول
لان مش معقوله اكون انا اكافح الفقر
والجوع والمرض وبعد كده هتكلم في هذه
القضايا اللي هي شويه تعتبر نخبويه الحديث
عن الحريات بياتي بعد ان البطون تكون
ملانه والابدان تكون صحيحه فلازم تاخد
فتره طويله ثم لازم الناس تتعايش وتتفق
على انه السودان للسودانيين ليس للشمال
ولا للجنوب ولا للمسيحيين ولا للمسلمين
فدي كلها عمليه تطور بتاخد سنين طويله جدا
علشان تستقر
الحلقه بتاعه الدوله الوحشه هتساعد حضرتك
والكتاب اللي قلت لحضرتك عليه للدكتور علي
الدين هلال وجيد جدا لانه كمان
بيغنيك عنك تقرا كتب كثيره باللغه
الانجليزيه في هذا الصدد
موضوع الرئيس السيسي على الدولار تابعته
ايه
تابعته ايه ما فهمتش وفعلا مش هيحصل تعويم
لا هو اللي انا جاوبت السؤال محمد امين
اللي انا فهمته الرئيس اعلنه قال انه
التعويم الان سوف يضر كثيرا جدا بالاقتصاد
المصري وبالناس وبالتالي انه هذا الامر
غير مطروحا الان
ده اللي قالوا معنى ذلك انه الناس توقعت
كلها انه لن يكون هناك تعويم وشيك كما كان
متوقع وفقا لتفهمات الحكومه مع صندوق
النقد ماذا سوف يحصل معهم مفاوضات صندوق
النقد مساله دلوقتي
في علم الغيب لان الصندوق المفروض انه لن
يوقع ولن يجري الاتفاق الا بعد تنفيذ
مشروطياته اللي هي مبنيه بالنسبه له على
فلسفه ونظام اقتصادي واضح
واظن انه الصندوق انتقد هذا التوجه لمصر
بشكل يعني غير مباشر
ونفس القصه في تونس الرئيس التونسي اخذ
نفس موقف الرئيس المصري هل هم عندهم بدائل
نحن لا نعلمها هل بيتفاوضوا على قروض
ثنائيه لا اعلم لكن ما اعلم وما اثق فيه
ان انت عندك الحسبه بسيطه
اما ان انت تعون
بالنسبه للدينار او الجنيه واذا كان
الجنيه الدولار الان بيساوي 30 جنيه
وهو في السوق بيساوي اربعين وممكن بعد كده
ينزل او يهبط اذا انت ما عملتش كده ما
خلتش الجنيه نفترض ان قيمته 40 النتيجه ان
هيحصل ايه ان مصر عندها احتياطات من
الدولار جاي لها من السياحه وجاي لها من
قناه السويس الى اخره وكذلك تونس من
مصادرها المختلفه اللي هيحصل ان انت هتوفر
الجنيه بدل ما بتوفره ب 40 بتوفروا ب 30
فانت توفره مدعوما كما تدعم رغيف الخبز
وكما تدعم
بعض انواع الادويه وهكذا او التعليم او
غيره هذا جيد لكن عندك قدره ان يكون عندك
تدفق دولاري يخليك تقدم الجنيه ب 30 بدل
سعره الحقيقي 40 ده محل سؤال لو انت عندك
دولارات كثيره ما فيش مشكله السعوديه
بتعمل كده الامارات بتعمل كده يعني مثبتين
عند سعر معين لكن لو ما عندكش هتستنفذ كل
الاحتياط اللي موجود في دعم الجنيه
والجنيه هيكون
يعتبر رخيص نسبيا عما يجب ان يكون عليه
وبالتالي انت هتستورد بكميات كبيره لانه
ده مش ده سعر مدعوم وبالتالي برضو هيبقى
عندك واردات هتستورد اكثر مما يجب
وبالتالي هيزيد الضغط على الاحتياطي
وبالتالي هتفصل في يوم من الايام اللي
بيجي عندكش دولارات وتلفلات الامور
فلازم اذا كنت هتقاوم شروط الصندوق لازم
يكون عندك تصور اخر هل لدى الحكومه تصور
اخر انا لا اعلمه لكن واضح ان طالما عندهم
القدره وبتكلموا انه لا لشروط الصندوق زي
ما بيقولوا الرئيس التونسي او لن نطبق
التعويم الان بالنسبه للرئيس المصري يبقى
اكيد عندهم تصور اخر
والا هيقولوا كده ازاي
استاذ سيد هل الصراع بين امريكا والصين
حتمين كما تم كما تم شرح حضرتك في موضوع
مصيده ثيوسيس
لا مش يعني
اللي اتكلم عليها
جرام الاستاذ اللي موجود في كيمبريدج اسف
بحاول افتكر اسمه ولكن
اسمه اعتقد جرين جرام لا اذكر ولكن كتابه
معروف اكتب كده على الانترنت دستن الطهور
دستن التورت امريكا يطلع لك اسم
البروفيسور جرام هو مجموعه من اصدقائه في
جامعه
البروفيسور عشان نذكر الناس قال انه انه
درس خمسمئه سنه او 600 سنه من الصراعات
واكتشف ان هناك نمط ثابت في الصراعات
النمط ده عباره عن ايه انه
بيكون نموذج في دوله سائده ودوله صاعده
على المستوى الاقليمي او المستوى العالمي
الدوله المهيمنه زي الولايات المتحده
والصاعده زي الصين بيحدث بينهم بيمروا
بمجموعه من المراحل اخر مرحله ان الدوله
المسيطره تشعر بقلق من الدوله الصاعده حتى
وان لم تسعى الدوله الصاعده انت تستفزها
بشكل مباشر مجرد وجودها مصدر لقلق للدوله
المهيمنه الساحه لا تتسع الى معرفش ايه
فحلين زي ما بيقول ولا
يعني
المراه لا يتسع الى فحلين او الى اسدين
وعليه عاده ده بينتهي بالصدام هو درس
ال500 سنه اللي فاتت فوجدت انه من 16 حاله
دوله قائمه في ال500 سنه ودوله صاعده 12
حاله انتهت بالصراع واربع حالات فقط لم
تنتهي بالصراع واحد اشهر الحالات الانتاج
بالسرعه طبعا الحرب العالميه الاولى
والحرب العالميه الثانيه بين بريطانيا
العظمى والمانيا اللي هي كانت صاعده او
المانيا
اليابان اللي صاعدتين وبريطانيا وفرنسا
القوى المهيمنه اهم مثال على عدم الصدام
بريطانيا سلمت قياده العالم لامريكا دون
صراع وطبعا ده سمي بسيدسس
لان المؤرخ في وسيدس اليوناني هو اللي وصف
هذا الصراع ما بين
اثينا الصاعده وسفاره المهيمنه فهو خد هذا
التعبير واطلقوا من فيوسيدس وسماه مصيده
اذا الرد المختصر
انه ليس حتميا وفقا للدراسه يعني ولكن
خصوصا انه ما كانش في ذهن
مش متاخد في الاعتبار انه في كل الامثله
اللي في ال500 سنه ان الدول هتتسلح باسلحه
دمار شامل قادره على تدمير العالم كله عده
مرات وبالتالي ربما تجمع هذه الدول للرشده
والعقل ويتعايشوا مع بعض يعني وتسلم
الولايات المتحده بان في دول قوه صاعده لن
تسمح لها بالسيطره على العالم الى الابد
اخو جبيل اود معرفه السير الذاتيه لسيادتك
الكريم انا من اقدم متابعيك ومحبينك الله
يحفظك واحب اعرف تاريخ عمل المهني وهو
مشرف بكل تاكيد واعذر جهلي بذلك لا يا
سيدي والله يا صقر الجنوب لا وانا متشكر
ان انت بتتابعني
يعني الاجابه المختصره انا وجدت ان في حد
عامل على ويكيبيديا تعريف صغير لشخص
المتواضع اذا دخلت عليه ممكن تاخد فكره
صغيره صحيح لما انا دخلت اصلحه علشان ادقق
فيه رفضوه ما اعرفش ويكيبيديا حد عمل لي
الصفحه بس انا نفسي ما عرفتش اصلحها لكن
كل القصه في اقل من نصف دقيقه انا صحفي
مصري
بشتغل صحفيا منذ
انهيت دراسته
وكانت دراستي في دراسه اللغه الانجليزيه
يعني
وبعد كده انا اشتغلت في كصحفي في الشؤون
الخارجيه لمتابعه قسم الشؤون الخارجيه
موجود في كل الصحف بدايه منذ ان انتهى
الخدمات العسكريه من اخر 92
وظللت على مدار الفتره الطويله ديت مهتم
بالشان الخارجي والشان الاقتصادي لان كان
عندي عشق للاقتصاد من فتره طويله وسعيده
كل السبل ان انا ادرسه واتوسع فيه ليس بس
حبا في الاقتصاد ولكن باعتباره زاويه مهمه
لفهم الشؤون العالميه لما بتشتغل صاحب في
الشؤون الخارجيه بيتيح لك انك تعرف من اول
يوم بتلتحق فيه في المهنه بانك بتتابع
كتير من اخبار العالم وكان لدي شغف من
البدايه ان نفسي يكون عندي تجربه تسمح لي
بانه لما اتكلم على شان دولي ان انا اعرضه
دون اصدار احكام اخلاقيه من بدري خالص
حبيت اعمل الكلام ده من اول الجراد اللي
اشتغلت فيها من منتصف التسعينات ولكن فشلت
في هذا فشلا ذريعا ولم يتسنى لي ذلك الا
بعد المنحله اليوتيوب هذه المنصه اللي انت
بتقول فيها رايك مش رايك تعرض فيها كيف
تفكر روسيا كيف تفكر اوكرانيا كيف تفكر
مصر كيف تفكر السعوديه باكبر قدر ممكن من
الموضوعيه ترصد الظاهره تحاول تبحثها
تحاول تعرضها بدون اصدار احكام اخلاقيه
وبدون ما تنظر على الناس
فالاجابه المختصره صحفي ليس اكثر يعني
هل علاقه الجزائر بروسيا لها
منافع تعود على الجزائر والعرب تعود على
الجزائر الجزائر
بتعبر عن مصالحها طبعا الجزائر في صراع
ومنافسه مع المغرب هذا لا يخفى على احد
والخلافه الرئيسي بينهم
هو طبعا قضيه الصحراء وقضيه الصحراء هي
بتعبر عن التنافس بين دولتين كل منهما
تسعى ان يكون لها نفوذ على منطقه شمال غرب
افريقيا والنفوذ معناها مصالح ومش عاوزه
الدوله التانيه تكون في طريقها علشان ده
يعيق مصالحها المغرب موجوده في في البلدين
في طرفي نقيض المغرب في المعسكر الغربي
وصديقه وحليفه للولايات المتحده ودول اخرى
ومؤخرا اسرائيل الجزائر بتشعر بان هي لابد
ان يكون لها اصدقاء قادرين يمدوها بدعم
يعادل الدعم الامريكي والعربي فهي بتعزز
علاقتها اكثر بروسيا والصين المغرب عندها
علاقات قويه بروسيا
وبروسيا والصين لكن كمان الصين عندها
علاقات جيده بدول غربيه كثيره يعني انما
الداعم رئيسي والحليف الرئيسي للجزائر هي
روسيا والصين ام الداعم الرئيسي للمغرب هي
الولايات المتحده وعليه فالجزائر مستفيده
من ان هي تحصل على اسلحه متقدمه لن تقدمها
لها الولايات المتحده
ومستفيده من الدعم الدبلوماسي اللي ممكن
تقدمهم لها تقدموا للجزائر في مجلس الامن
باعتبار ان لها حق الفيتو مستفيده من
التعاون مع دوله كبرى زي روسيا وروسيا
مستفيده طبعا ان يكون لها حليف بيشتري
منها بمليارات الدولارات سنويا سلاح وحبوب
وسلع رئيسه ومتفهم لمصالح الروس
ويعني البلديه المستفيدين
امين من المغرب بيقول السلام عليكم عليكم
السلام يا صديقي شكرا على مجهودك في
القناتين نعرف ونعرف اقتصاد
انا
محمد ماهر هل من الدقيق القول بان مصر هي
الدوله العربيه القادره على مواجهه النفوذ
الايراني استاذنكم لحظه
هل من الدقيق القول بان مصر هي الدوله
العربيه القادره على مجامله النفوذ
الايراني والتركي على الدول العربيه
وانه لولا ضعف النفوذ مصر الخارجي لما
تغلغلت ايران وتركيا في العراق وسوريا
اظن محمد مش دقيق يعني مصر لعبه دور قيادي
كبير في العالم العربي هذا لا يخفى على
احد بس حتى لما كان مصر لها دور قيادي
كبير
طبعا دقلص يعني من نفوذ دول اخرى في
المنطقه باعتبار انه تخيل حد من نفوذ مصر
ايام جمال عبد الناصر في العالم العربي
كانت هذه الدول لها نفوذ ايضا ولكن اقل
بكثير بس الدنيا تغيرت تماما يعني مصر حتى
لو كان لها حجم هذا النفوذ الكبير
الان نسبيا يعني صعب ان انت تتخيله في
فتره الخمسينات والستينات خمسينات والسند
كانت في دول عربيه لم تولد بعد والدول
العربيه كانت مولوده وحديثه العهد فقصه
المقارنه صعب لكن اللي عاوز اقوله انه غير
دقيق بمعنى ان تراجع النفوذ المصري
الخارجي بسبب انتفاء مصر على مشاكلها
الداخليه عامل في تغلق هذه الدول كبير
ولكن ليس وحيد لانه ما تنساش ان العالم
العربي تعرض على مجموعه من الصدمات الصدمه
الاولى انهيار العراق وجود العراق كان
كافيا انه يحمل عمليه ترضع له كلا من
الايران ومن وده اللي كان حاصل ثم انهيار
سوريا سوريا كان وجودها واقفه على قدميها
سبب رئيسي ايضا لوضع تركيا في مكانها ايوه
تركيا طول عمرها اقوى عسكريا ولكن ما كانش
عندها الاستعداد او الجراه ان هي تحتل 10%
من سوريا كما هو حادث الان الدول ديت
تحركت في فراغ بعد انهيار العراق تراجع
النفود المصري اه ثم انهيار العراق ثم
الربيع العربي الذي اتى على دول العربيه
كثيره
فاتمنى اكون اجبت على سؤال حضرتك
وانا الحقيقه كانت النيه ان انا استاذنكم
انهي الحلقه عند الساعه العاشره لوجود ظرف
طارق عندي بس انا كمان هكمل ربع ساعه
واستاذن الاصدقاء اللي انا ما اجبتش
اسئلتهم ان احنا نجيبها في حلقه اخرى ان
شاء الله
هل يستغل العرب انشغال الولايات المتحده
بالحرب مع الصين من اجل التخلص من الكيان
الصهي
والله يا خالد يا ريت بس الكيان الصهيوني
اللي بتقول عليه ده اصبح دوله لديه
امكانيات اكبر من كل الدول العربيه مجتمعه
ثم ان الولايات المتحده ما هياش دوله
صغيره بتنشغل بمشكله وابتدها عن العالم
كله وهي عامله زي الاخطبوط لديها اصابع في
كل مكان
تحيه طيبه هل الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه او
شكت على الانتهاء ده براين في تقدير لا في
تقدير ينطبق عليها قول المتنبي
طريقنا ام يطولوا لسه قدامنا حتى لو حصل
هدنه حتى لو حصل
استراحه خلصت قله الناس اجهدت حصل وقف
اطلاق نار وتيفر لكن الصراع مستمر كثيرا
يعني
هل المنطقه مقبله على نهض اقتصاديه معينه
كون ان الجميع يعلن عن رؤى اقتصاديه كبرى
ومشاريع كبرى وتحالفات اقتصاديه مثل الشام
الجديد لا والله ما حدش بيعلن عن مشاريع
اقتصاديه ضخمه ولا حاجه غير الدول اللي
عندها فائض
والدول اللي عندها فائق يمين هي محدوده
جدا انت بتتكلم على السعوديه باعتبارها
اكبر اقتصاد في العالم العربي والظروف
ساعدتها في حين انه الدول بتعاني من مشاكل
هم ما شاء الله استفادوا من الطفره اللي
موجوده في البترول دوله زي قطر الدوله مش
دول كثيره حتى الكويت مقدرتش ان هي تستفيد
من طفره الاسعار بسبب يعني يعني
بسبب الخلافات الدائمه بين النخب الحاكمه
في الكويت فمش كل الدول ولا حاجه
بينما
يعني بقيه الدول وحتى الدول الخليجيه اللي
اعلنت اتمنى ان هم ينجحوا بس هم سبق لهم
واعلنوا ذلك كثيرا النموذج اللي نجح كان
الامارات نجح في ايه في ان هو خرج من
مشكله
الاعتماد الكلي على البترول اصبحوا اقل
اعتمادا من البترول نتمنى ان بقيه الدول
تنجح واللي يبدو انه السعوديه في الفتره
الاخيره
خدت المساله بجديه اكبر مما اخذته حكومات
اخرى سابقه يعني
الشامل الجديد يعني
اللي هو انت بتتكلم على العراق والاردن
ومصر هو دول بتتعاون فيما بينها
وعلى اساس يعني
مش تحالف اقتصادي بالمعنى اللي هو يعني
اكتر من انه تلات دول ظروفهم صعبه والتلات
اقتصادين يعني والتلات دول لديهم ما
يقدموا كل منهم للاخر
انما ده ما يعملش الطفره المقوله على
اعتبار ان الدول دي علاقتها ما كانتش
مقطوعه اللي يعمل طفره مهوله طبعا انه كل
دوله من دول الاول تتجاوز مشاكلها
الاقتصاديه ثم يكون التعاون مع الدول
الاخرى عامل مساعد انما هو لوحده كده ما
يعملش طفره يعني
حسين بيقول السلام عليكم ارجو من حضرتك
عرض لنا سلسله حلقات عن الحرب العالميه
الاولى والثانيه وكذلك كيف نحصل على
المعلومات من مصدر الموثوقه قناه او موقع
اخباري
الحرب العالميه الاولى انا مهتم بها وحاضر
الحرب العالميه الاولى هي الاكثر غرابه
يعني لانه اذا عرفنا الحرب العالميه
الاولى بنفهم الحرب العالميه الثانيه لانه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ليست الا امتدادا
للحرب العالميه الاولى حاضر
اما الجزء الثاني اللي حضرتك بتقول عليه
بقى المواقع والاخبار والقنوات الموثوق
منها
فما عنديش اجابه بسيطه وببقى يعني محرج ان
انا اقول انه يعني تبقى الاجابه يعني ناس
عاوزين مثلا واحد اتنين تلاته ما فيش واحد
اتنين تلاته انت علشان تحصل على اخباره
موثوق فيها الاسف
ربما لا يكون متاحا لرجل طبيب او مدرس او
محامي يعني ما بيشتغلش في مهنه المعلومات
معظم القنوات لديها اجنداتها معظم القنوات
لديها توجهاتها انت علشان يبقى عندك قناه
بتثق فيها اقتصاديا او كذا لازم تاخد فكره
عن اكتر من قناه
وتسمع الخبر من كذا زاويه يعني انا لو
عاوز اعرف خبر مثلا عن الحرب في اوكرانيا
بس مع
المصادر البريطانيه بس انا عارف ان
بريطانيا والولايات المتحده والغرب رغم
الحريه اللي موجوده عندهم معظم القنوات هي
بتحاول تطلع ان روسيا
شريره وفاشله وبيقولوا كلام يصل الى حد
يعني السخف في هذا الصند اذا رحت للمواقع
الروسيه في مواقع محترمه وجيده لكن هي
معظمها يذهب الى انه الروس يعني منتصرون
منتصرون فانا بسمع من الروس وبحذف الجزء
اللي انا عارف ان هم ممكن يكونوا بيحاولوا
يصدروا لاسباب اندعائيه او يعني قناعتهم
او كذا باخد من بريطانيا وبحذف الجزء اللي
انا عارف
فده محتاج تدريب يعني محتاج ان انت تشوف
اكتر من قناه وانت بتعمل ده يعني بالوقت
هتلاقي نفسك بتحصل عمليه فرز
طبيعي بتتابع فبتلاقي ان القناه دي جربتها
مره واتنين وتلاته كانت قناه دقيقه اديتك
معلومه سليمه انه كذا فهتلاقي مع الوقت
العمليه بتتم بشكل تلقائي
[موسيقى]
ولو بتعرف لغه انجليزيه
انا بقول الانجليزيه ما بعرفش اللغات
تانيه اكيد اللغات التانيه فيها حاجات
عظيمه بس انا ما بعرفش غير انجليزي هتجد
انه مهمتك تكون اسهل كتير لانه رغم التلون
ورغم وجود يعني
تحيزات ورغم ان هم مش عايشين يعني في عالم
مثالي الا ان ما تاخذه من صحيفه زي بولس
ما تاخذه من صحيفه زي نيويورك تايمز ما
تاخذه من صحيفه زي بريطانيه
هيكون اكثر دقه واكثر تدقيقا بكثير جدا
جدا مما تحصل عليه من المواقع العربيه
محتاجين راي حضرتك في مشكله قانون الايجار
القديم وايه الحل من وجهه نظرك داري حاب
يا ريت والله يا رحاب انا يعني هذا خارج
اهتمامي خالص او انا لا اعلم بشيء
بالمناسبه كانت اتصل بيا
يعني احد
الاساتذه مشكورا يعني
ولقيته انه هو جاب تليفونك كتر خيره يعني
انه عرض علي تصور وموضوع الايجار القديم
وكابتن عنده معلومات هائله يمكن يكون
بيسمعني دلوقتي بس الحقيقه احنا قناتنا
على العلاقات الدوليه والشعنقه يعني مش
قناه محليه تتكلم عن العقار او الشان
المصري او او دوله معينه يعني
اسف يا رحاب
استاذ جبيل مئات الالاف من السوريين حصلوا
على الجنسيه في اوروبا ويوجد غيرهم في
الانتظار والغالبيه الساحقه من المعارضه
هل من الممكن ان يشكل هذا ضغطا على نظام
الاسد لاسقاته عبر ضغطهم على الحكومات
الاوروبيه هم الحكومه الاوروبيه محتاجه
ضغط الالاف او عشرات الالاف اللي حصلوا
على الجنسيات ما الحكومات الاوروبيه كان
عندها حافز ضخم جدا لاسقاطه واستعانت
بالدول العربيه والدول الاوروبيه والدول
العربيه
ودول الاوروبيه والعربيه مع تركيا لان
تركيا لعبت دور اكبر والولايات المتحده
انفقوا مليارات الدولارات لاسقاط الاسد
وتعثر الفكره واصبحوا الان ما بيبذلوش جهد
لانه هم ياسوا من المساله
لا اشك يعني اشك ان تعادل قاره مره اخرى
يعني
علي الصحفي العربي الوحيد الذي يفكر
ويقارب الامور بطريقه علميه شكرا لكل ما
قدمته وتقدمه الله يخليك عليه
يعطيك العافيه استاذنا ما هي فرص اشتعال
حرب او مواجهه بين اسرائيل وجبهه الشمال
يقصد لبنان وهل من الممكن ان تكون حرب
استنزاف لايران وايضا ما هي فرص ضم الضفه
الغربيه او اجتماع اجتياح عسكري اسرائيلي
كذا نقطه فرصه ضم الضفه الغربيه
لا اراها يعني في الفرسيه بالفيوتشر او
المستقبل القريب لانه سوف يكون جنان في
جنان في جنان ايوه صحيح ان يحكم اسرائيل
بالغوا التطرف والجنان لكن اشك في النهايه
انه ده ممكن يحدث يعني ليس ليس في
المستقبل المنظور هل يمكن ان يحدث اجتياح
او عمليه عسكريه في الضفه قد تكون عمليه
عسكريه وارده ايوه محدوده
لان محدش مستفيد من تصعيد واسع يعني خصوصا
ان هذا الاجتياح اذا كان واسعا قد يكون من
نتائجه ان تسقط السلطه الفلسطينيه اذا
ساقطت ايكون تاثيرها اسوا على
الاسرائيليين من على الفلسطينيين
ده تصوري يعني قد اكون مخطئ بالنسبه لي
حرب يعني اشتعال حرب ما بين اسرائيل وحرب
حزب الله ده احتمال وارد من 2006 من اخر
مواجهه كبيره بينهم يعني وارد طوال الوقت
ولكن لاحظ لما حدثت اكتشتات من شهور قليله
يعني شهرين تلاته حزب الله مش حزب الله
يعني جماعات من جنوب لبنان
اطلقت قذائف قليله اصابه الاسرائيليين رد
الاسرائيليون بقذف مماثل في اماكن فارغه
فارغه لان كل طرف
لا يريد
يعني حربا وبالتالي بيمارسوا ضبط نفس
عنيف جدا
وهم عارفين قواعد الاشتباك فيما بينهم ولن
يخاطروا بهذه الحرب الا لاسباب قويه هل ده
ممكن يحصل ممكن تتحول الى استنزاف لصالح
ايران ممكن انما هذا يعني غير مرحب به لا
من ايران ولا من اسرائيل ولو اسرائيل كان
عندها القدره لها هاجمه ايران وصفت يعني
ترسيناتها النوويه ولو كانت ايران تقدر
لفعلتها بس لا تقدر ولا من مصلحتها ففي
نوع من تكافؤ القوى يعني
مساء الخير يا رب الاربعاء القادم يكون
عيد الاضحى انا من جهتي بحب اعيد معك
مباشره مباشره احلى عيديه الله يخليك يا
احمد والله انا شاكر جدا ليك بس استمتع
بالعيد من غير مباشر لا انت عندك اكيد
حاجات احلى ممكن تسمعها كتر الف خيرك يعني
محمد بيقول تحياتي
لا مش محمد محمود بيقول تحياتي وتقديري
وحب الشديد لك يا استاذ سيد كيف ترى
التارجح اسعار الذهب وماذا تنصح
المستثمرين فين شكرا جزيلا على كلامك
الطيب اما فيما يتعلق بنصائح لمستثمرين
تعلق بالذهب هذا تماما خارج يعني خبراتي
يعني لا استطيع ابدا ان انا اقوم باعطاء
اي نصائح لمستثمرين يعني فسامحني
خالد استاذ سيد دايما اسالك السؤال ولكن
للاسف لا تقرا اهو ده دورك والله يا ريت
اهو لماذا لا تقوم روسيا ببناء قاعده
عسكريه في امريكا اللاتينيه كفنزويلا مثلا
وبالتالي تكون قريبه من الولايات المتحده
وتنهي حرب اوكرانيا وتحرق الغرب انا قرات
سؤالك واللي ما تمكنش اراء قبل كده خالص
والاجابه باختصار لان الولايات المتحده لن
تسمح بذلك
والدول انا انا عارف الاجابه اللي حضرتك
يعني هي تسمح ولا لا مهمه روسيا هقول
لحضرتك الولايات المتحده كقوه عظمى لن
تسمح بذلك
والدول اللي ممكن تستقبل قاعده لن تسمح
للروس بذلك حتى لا تتعرض الى غضب الولايات
المتحده
في اكتوبر 62
وانتهت بحصار الولايات المتحده لكوبا
بالقاعده العسكريه الروسيه
وكاد العالم ينزلق الى حرب عالميه ثالثه
وانتهت الازمه بان الروس سحبوا صواريخهم
من كوبا التي وضعت سرا في غفله من
الامريكان
ولها قصص لطيفه يعني ممكن
لما تيجي فرصه نتكلم عنها يعني وفي مقابل
ان الامريكان تعهدوا بامرين امر علني الا
يغزوا الجزيره التي كانوا يهددون بغزوها
فكانت حليفه للاتحاد السوفيتي الامر
الثاني
ان هم يفككوا القواعد التي نصبوها على
تركيا والتي كانت تهدد الاتحاد السوفيتي
بالمناسبه اثير في الاسبوعين اللي فاتوا
ان الصين بتبني قاعده تجسس في كوبا
والولايات المتحده انكرت في البدايه ثم
اقرت والقت باللائمه على
على الادارات السابقه وجاري التفاوض على
يعني مع الصين في مفاوضاتهم ما مصير هذه
القاعده اللي كشفتها صحيفه اول مره
هنا بقى السؤال طب ليه الولايات المتحده
تسمح لنفسها ببناء قواعد عسكريه وتضم دول
على حدود روسيا او الصين لانها كانت اقوى
ولما حاولت روسيا ان تعترض على دم دول
مثلا اللي هو بلطيق
مثلا
وشقيقتها الدول ديت
دمت وهي كانت دول سابقه للاتحاد السوفيتي
ومجاوره تماما وليه دول انت عندك بعد كده
فنلندا
والنمسا الى اخره بس انا بتكلم على 2004
كانت روسيا ضعيفه جدا فبالتالي ما قدرتش
تعترض لما روسيا قويات اعترضت زي ما قلت
لكم في اول الحلقه على انضمام جورجيا اللي
عندها حدود مع روسيا ثم انضم اعترضت على
انضمام اوكرانيا وخارت حربا بسبب اصرار في
الولايات المتحده ضم هذه الدول اليها لحلف
شمال الاطلسي وبالتالي بناء قواعد عسكريه
هناك فالمساله مساله قوه لا اكثر ولا اقل
يعني
اخبار الصناعه المصريه
ده علاء انا مش يعني مش متابع الحقيقه
انا بقدر اقول يعني ايه انه
ما اعلمه انا يعني من زمايل اللي هم
متخاصمين في مجال التصنيع وكذا انه لا
الصناعه المصريه بتعاني معاناه شديده احنا
متاخرين جدا جدا جدا في هذا الملف
احنا قدامنا دقيقتين ما اسباب تفوق
الصناعه العسكريه الفرنسيه
واحده من دول العالم الكبرى اقتصادها اللي
هو حوالي اتنين وتمانيه من عشره تريليون
دولار زي
بريطانيه كده هي اكتر شويه من بريطانيا قد
كل الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لكل الدول
العربيه عندهم علماء في كل المجالات عندهم
تعليم متطور جدا عندهم
مبتكرين عندهم حريه عندهم ديمقراطيه
وبالتالي مش غريبه خالص خالص انه يكون بلد
عنده تعليم متفوق
التعليم المتفوق ده افرز علماء يؤدي الى
صناعه متطوره في كل المجالات ومن بينها
الصناعات العسكريه الراجل اللي بيقدر يصنع
سياره ويقدر يصنع
قمر صناعي واللي يقدر يصنع كمبيوتر فائق
التطور يقدر يصنع اكيد صاروخ ويقدر يصنع
دبابه وهكذا فالصناعات العسكريه ليست
استثناء هم مجموعه من العلماء
عندهم القدره انه يطوروا صناعات مختلفه
والصناعات العسكريه جزء منها
انا هستاذنكم
لا اسف يعني
انا عارف ان في اسئله كثيره جدا بس
سامحوني والله
انا النهارده كان صعب جدا انه المباشر يتم
لاسباب طريقه جاءتني بس انا حتى الاصدقاء
وعمر قالوا لي النهارده نعتذر قلت له انا
يعني
اعلنته ولا ارغب في ان انا
يعني لا اتم ما اعلنت عنه فانا اسف انا
هقف هنا انا اجبت عن جزء من الاسئله وفي
اسئله تانيه استاذنكم
حين يجمعنا الله على خير ان شاء الله
الاربعاء بعد القادم ان شاء الله اجيب
عنها اللي انا ما جاوبت السؤال وسامحني
ويعلم الله انا يعني احنا عملنا النهارده
المباشر ده ازاي واقول لكم كل سنه
وحضراتكم طيبين
وان شاء الله ان شاء الله نلتقي على خير
بعد العيد اشكركم والى لقاء